I gotta give I'm messing with audio
setup today we're gonna be doing the
podcast without monitoring headphones
because hopefully we get our volumes
correct I know well I can't like what if
I just start gesturing towards you and
and I turn my head and I don't realize
that I'm not being recorded
then our listeners will get the real
experience of crappier
you're welcome everybody but for serious
in today's podcast we're gonna be
talking about this this kind of week
where we haven't published a video it's
the first time we've done that
intentionally ever yeah where we like
could have you know powered through and
made ourselves doing and we decided not
to we have yeah in the past like when we
first started up taken off weeks because
like we were traveling or we had work
stuff and things like that boo the first
time where we like intentionally
preemptively took a week off from
publishing a video yeah so in today's
episode we're gonna be talking about
what's new what happened during that
week outsourcing and diversifying
because that's some of the things that
we kind of took on during that like it's
not free time but it's like we keep
calling it a week off but we've been
working just as late if not later but
we've relaxed the deadlines we've taken
on things that have coming up we've
tackled things that we've wanted to
tackle for a long time that we couldn't
fit into a week that we couldn't fit in
a normal week and it's it's kind of like
because we've been so under all of these
deadlines that we have set for ourselves
we we've been tackling the urgent and
important things but I feel like there's
been a lot of urgent yet not important
things we've been leaving the table
you mean opposite important but not
urgent yes thank you for the save yeah
there's a lot of things that are really
important to us but just like not urgent
in the moment like they're very good
they're gonna be very important for us
in the long term so let's start with
kind of going back a little bit to what
what happened during that week off well
we started it with my mom visiting
super-fun and it kind of worked out
because if she'd visited any week prior
we would have liked not been able to see
her at all while she was here and we
still like I always feel weird when we
have people visit because I'm like we
can hang out together for me like please
make yourself at home I mean but my mom
is like pretty good about doing that you
know like go pick up some things that
she needs like run errands or just like
hang out and watch YouTube we showed her
the try guys loved the try guys and she
was like oh my gosh I'm gonna binge that
there's also great because it's
interesting to share kind of not not
really actively share but like have
someone witnessed what we do in a day
which is basically wake up work work
work tackle all these diverse things and
turn them into finished pieces of
content for the internet yeah it's
always cool and we get to like be with
someone when they see the
behind-the-scenes of something and then
they get to see the final one and
sometimes we get to do that with you
guys in the form of like streaming like
when we do some workshop streams but
there is a lot more that goes into stuff
like making decisions about edits and
things like that and so she got to like
hang out with us while we discussed that
type of stuff and we even didn't we like
bounce some stuff off of her I think oh
the UM resin cubes idea we have this
idea of fair future project to like test
a bunch of to test a bunch of mixers and
fillers and stuff that you can put in
resin and we were wondering like do we
do everything in one big video or do we
break it up into multiple and we could
like bounce ideas off of you know an
outside person which was cool yeah one
and the whole idea of working at a more
sustainable pace is we can take a little
bit of time off for the things that we
want to make and make time for in our
life so like eventually would like to be
able to take a little bit more time off
and just hang out together do things
together that aren't our job then we
want to add in like working out a little
bit more that's
a high priority for us that we just
haven't been able to fit in every other
day the like workout reminder it's a
little bit dramatic to say that we don't
have 20 minutes in our day to fit
working out in but we do but it's gonna
be sacrificing something and something
something is are always sacrificed but
then I think another thing that we want
to do more of in the future is take out
time from our lives to spend with family
and friends and that's something we did
a little bit of during during this week
off it seems like come up with a better
word for this like the worst rotation
rotation yeah it's like you know the
vacation there's staycations in this
rotation where you work but you don't
work on the normal stuff you work on I
guess that's not fully because we did
still work video today but we did take
on some additional things yeah work is a
work occasionally ok guys let us know in
the comments below like I don't know but
also it's like we need to name this this
this week because we're gonna be doing
more of these in the future and it'd be
cool to have a week so get catch up week
catch up week like you know we had we
had our our whole my whole family over
and your mom was here and they kind of
had like we kind of hosted people at our
house cool because you know in our daily
lives we are an awesome team tackling
content and making the stuff together
and I think that it's kind of cool
seeing some of that teamwork translated
into like a normal everyday situation of
like hosting a bunch of people it's like
it's like we knew what each other was
doing and like we're both working on the
same goals and like passing off cooking
tasks and planning and shopping and
coordinating and everything we have been
playing we just recently finished
overcooked one we've been streaming and
like oh my gosh we're over cooked in
real life because I mean and we cook all
the time you need to tell them what
overcooked is Oh
overcooked is a game where basically
you're these little chefs and you're
cooking meals but it's like the most
stressful game it's so stressful and you
have to coordinate so much because the
levels changing and like I'm cooking a
burrito over here I mean yeah and then
like we do like pass things around and
like you're in like a space station
where things just rotate or you're on
like a lava level and stuff consulting
thing is this kind of like a it's like a
test of communication and like juggling
a whole bunch of thing this at once you
know you have to look at what orders are
coming in what's going out and it's
interesting it's a it's a it's
definitely like a stress test for your
your teamwork before people would say
like oh to test your relationship like
go to Ikea together like play over cook
together yeah between like you me and my
mom cuz my mom helped out a lot with
like picking up some stuff and doing
some like prep work and she made dessert
we're all like oh yeah you got this yeah
oh I'll do dishes hey check that
broccoli yeah and then by the end by the
time my family left we spent like two
minutes wrapping up the last of the
dishes and we were done
yeah it was magical that was pretty
impressive I was pretty impressive like
only have two minutes worth of dish
washing at the end of having like eight
people I mean like us it kind of says
shows like you know people ask us a lot
like what's it like working together and
and everything and it's like we're just
improving our communication we're
improving our teamwork we're improving
my relationship and everything and we
haven't really had the place to test
that because all we do is work but like
you know we we hosted the dinner which
is a stressful thing for some people but
it was like everything was went
perfectly smooth and everything and then
we're like we should do this more often
we'll probably do it twice a year yeah
but I think that that's something that
we can work on and part of that is
outsourcing and diversifying look at you
in your Segway Hey
so I think interestingly enough these
are both a problem and solution to a lot
of issues you know it's like we've been
working on evident Caitlyn making our
videos feel more like us making them
more natural figuring out how to edit
and shoot them faster and we have been
doing that we've been doing that really
well mm-hmm and when did we kind of like
get into our groove probably like
January of this year well I mean we
talked about this in the very first
episode of the podcast where we talked
about our different stages and different
inspirations on update because in the
first episode we haven't done some of
the laps from the changes that we go
through yeah spontaneous update yes
funniest update so so the very first
episode that we published for the
podcast was it was in January right yeah
and since then I think that we've kind
of completed this pivot in in some way
where we've pivoted more towards
entertainment with a dose of tips and
inspiration and DIY awesomeness and that
has kind of taken off a little bit oh
yeah oh yeah you know we might just
totally derail this podcast we could
talk about this for a while we could
talk about this for a while for another
time we should probably like say this
for a whole podcast right yeah this
should be a whole podcast
okay okay okay future podcast unlike the
past couple months
cuz there's been some crazy there has
been some crazy stuff going on shifts
behind the teams like in our heads and
like with our views okay well anyways as
we've been like as we've been figuring
out our video which is I guess what I
was gonna talk about so I feel like we
have figured out our video production
now we kind of know what we're doing we
know how to do it we have like a fairly
known procedure and if we just did Evan
and Caitlin videos one per week or maybe
three per month
we would actually have a decent amount
more free time yes yes but that is not
the case because we have been
diversifying we have started this
podcast which you're listening to or
watching right now and we've also
started ramping up evident
we've started I mean we stream on Twitch
like a couple times a week on average
some some weeks or a lot more sometimes
we'll skip a week but but it's been
really fun like just last week we've
kind of established that as a real thing
I mean I did some very rough edits you
did some rough edits of our footage but
I think that because we want people to
be able to watch it even if they can't
join the stream and it's it's a lot to
go back and watch a two-hour live stream
not live yeah but so we wanted to the
edits you're talking about are like
highlights of our streams yeah but in
that diversification we can't like the
two people that run evident kay lemons
can't not only plan film and edit and
Evan and Kaitlyn main video every week
plan a podcast and then stream and edit
a video game highlight every week that's
just like not physically emotionally
logically possible so we've been
diversifying and I think that's led to
some very interesting thoughts
discoveries growth all sorts of things
and that's kind of the main thing that
we wanted to talk about today and I
think that the whole shift towards
diversifying has kind of made us think
about our time and outsourcing in a very
different way and relating it to things
in everyone's everyday life yeah you
sounded like you were gonna continue
yeah well I think um uh oh you reach
informa you're gonna steal some mighty
yes I am okay the London Fog Lotte
you're welcome um so yeah so outsourcing
and diversifying has definitely been
tied together because we've been
diversifying and diversifying and we
cannot keep up with ourselves and so
we've started
outsourcing some of the edits for our
games and we've started outsourcing
closed captions for our videos yeah and
we've started outsourcing some website
website help yeah kind of the order that
that winton actually is actually
opposite so so um I think actually
captions came first yeah and oh my gosh
that was the easiest decision we've ever
made because captions really helped
videos I feel like they're important
especially now that autoplay happens on
the home screen yeah you know when
you're on your phone on mobile and you
like hover over a video too long and it
starts Auto playing silently but you see
the captions I think that's super
important because I I will sit there and
watch like a minute of video just
reading the captions and I'm like oh
wait that's crazy I think it's like
really important I think it's important
and we would it will take us like
seriously an hour maybe maybe more for a
lot more for like a 20 minute video
maybe more cuz it's not you know if you
think about there's a lot of videos
where like people don't talk very much
you know even in the maker community and
talk alone yeah I mean think like Jimi
dress has got no captions you know but
we talk a lot and it's extra hard
because we are two people talking over
each other a lot and so it's it's just
yeah it's just a lot it would oh my gosh
I just put up my hair in a ponytail okay
for those of you who are listening but
like I think that captions are perfect
example of what to outsource because
there there's nothing that we can do
better than someone else yeah we're
actually worse I think it's like if I'm
off screen and I'm talking they put
Caitlyn you know : words and then they
put like the sounds they put like the
music marks loudly passive aggressive
like we're making them watch this video
and they're not enjoying it or something
like like we've gotten like eight videos
captioned or something and all of them
were really good except this one has
like every laughing
laughs that was like laughs loudly they
never put laughs laughs laughs loudly
okay there's really easy to change and
everything we just I left one laughing
loudly in there
yeah I think it would be funny to see
what they say what cause like they have
to choose what certain noises are when
there's not like letters you can put to
that noise yeah so what if it's one
where I'm just like having like Caitlyn
groans like you know it's like it's
funny it's funny see well that was like
the easiest one to pass off the the next
one that I try to pass off that I
thought would be really easy is for
people to write things on a website like
to kind of because we make our videos
and we used to write tutorials on a
website
but our website doesn't get much traffic
Instructables got some and image roll
got some when we translated that text
and image into those other mediums but
still it would take several it takes
several hours like four or five hours
yeah to go through a video pull all the
screen caps write all the steps
especially doing it to like the level we
would want to do it at and then it
doesn't really bring us any you know so
it's hard to say motivates me that we
were beginning and starting up it was
totally totally totally worth it it was
for any percent of our traffic came from
yeah outside sources and that was us
like putting it on Instructables yeah
and and some of the reason why were
getting no external traffic from those
old types is because we don't do it
anymore but even when we did it was
pretty miniscule and it was diminishing
returns like making another video was a
lot more important then exactly yeah we
could put four to five hours towards a
video or four to five hours towards an
article yeah but like the article
writing it's interesting because when we
write we write in our voice and that
that that comes across because we're not
doing like kind of like a corporate
business tea type blog post or something
like that where it's just like factual
and all of that so it was interesting
trying to outsource that because it was
really hard yeah we thought it would be
easier for some like
to be easy for some reason but yeah it's
hard to find someone that can like
translate your voice and I guess like I
go back and forth because I feel like
you know the purpose of the written
articles is more for instruction because
you know there's stuff that we can't
always fit into a video instruction wise
so like how entertaining does it have to
be but we don't want it to not sound
well we don't want to be like totally
off-brand you know yeah so that's that's
been definitely an adventure but I think
the one I am most excited about is
evident Caitlyn gaming what I did is
have we officially announced that on the
podcast we talked about game like twitch
streaming and stuff I guess we were kind
of getting towards it earlier that like
we've been doing highlights yeah we have
another a whole nother channel that we
don't talk about much because until
recently it's been kind of lackluster
but now like we have some legit videos
on there yeah Caitlyn gaming I mean this
is getting into like SEO I'm kind of
going off the rails here a little bit
but I think that one one strategy we've
come up for for launching the things
that are are in their infancy as you
announce it on the platform where you
have the smallest following and you get
those people over there and then you
mount it on a platform where you have a
little bit bigger following and you get
people over there and as you grow that
following that legitimizes the new thing
more and more and more and makes it more
of a things that when you by the time
you announce it on your biggest platform
it it's a thing you know you're not long
I think I think like to replace the word
thing with real words I think it's more
about you know if you if you immediately
launch something new to your biggest
audience which for us that would be on
YouTube and you only have a few
subscribers you know there's definitely
like a groupthink thing that happens on
channels where the more subscribers a
channel has the more likely you are to
subscribe to it because like the crowd
made it yeah has endorsed it as
something worthy um and so like by the
time we launched our biggest on our
biggest platform we want to have built
up as
many subscribers from launching on our
smaller platforms as possible yeah so
that's kind of why we haven't made as
big of a deal about it yeah when people
find the dark whoa you have a gaming
channel awesome and stuff you know so
that's that's where we're going with
that but and I know it might seem like
kind of random especially if you know
you're tuning in to the podcast for the
first time or you haven't heard us talk
about this elsewhere but like games are
a pretty big like we're a pretty big
part of our lives yeah we both really
like playing video games we used to play
video games like individually a lot
growing up and like went together once
we started dating and it's definitely
been something on our minds and we've
gone on walks and we've spent like the
whole like like 15 20 minute walk just
talking about like why we don't enjoy
video games and he like like you know
why why we can't make why video games
aren't a priority for us anymore because
we have to play video games so much yeah
but I think like that the conclusion we
came to is they just don't give us as
much long-term value as like fixing up a
house or making videos or working or
anything like that like yeah I mean well
to put it simply it was cuz they weren't
work those other things they were yeah
work and when you have so much work
taking time away from it means that
you're gonna have to pay later yeah you
know I think that when you when we were
working normal day jobs we would you
know work our normal day job come back
and that time was ours you know you
obviously have to take care of like your
house your family your friends this and
that but you would have like personal
time where you were like you weren't at
all expected to work yeah and we're
working more wouldn't really benefit you
in any way but for our situation the
more we work the more we benefit you
know it's very hard to stop
so making video games into something
that means something for us long-term
and gives us long-term value is the way
to like hack our brains into playing and
enjoying video games again
yeah it's been such a fun journey to be
on again it's been so fun it's been so
fun and I don't know it just makes me
really happy
didn't do that and I think that we were
completely fine with a just growing art
which following because we just play the
games and were done but like I knew that
there is more potential there and I just
have this like really strong internal
drive an internal feeling about evident
Caitlyn gaming and it took a little bit
to like bring Caitlyn around because I
was like your feeling was like okay we
need to make this into something you
edited a few streams they were they're
really funny but it takes a long time it
takes a long time hours of footage hours
of stream footage and so you were like
hey I think maybe we should like see if
someone else wants to edit our streams
and I was like are you sure you want to
do that because we're not making any
money on evident Caitlyn gaming and I
don't know if it makes sense to pay
someone to edit people spending hundreds
of dollars on something that we're
making nothing from exactly but you had
a feeling I had a feeling I had a
feeling so you know I'll leave links
below to the resources that we've done
so I'll leave a link to rev Fiverr and
feelings or fibers where we did some of
the article and website work and the
website we didn't really touch on that
too much this because it's not really
exciting it's like fixing back-end SEO
and formatting and theme issues and
stuff that's like the least interesting
part of all of this but um freelancer
comm has been very interesting it was a
little bit of a pain to set up our
profile and get everything working and
stuff and sift through some of the like
the spam that we got in terms of the
bids but we found some really awesome
editors there yeah found some really
awesome creative people on there that
just needed a chance to show what they
could do you know and I think it's been
really interesting working with them and
I think that Caitlyn has been kind of
dealing with the evident Caitlyn gaming
or evident Kalyan main edits of the
videos and all that while I've been kind
of exploring this and I've definitely
learned a lot I definitely kind of
didn't do the best job with the first
attempt at like getting help because I
kind of put out generally what we wanted
and like like I could I didn't give the
most clear
instructions with very good guidance but
I put out the first one I got something
back
Kate and I discussed it we put out
another one so we've worked with three
editors to make three different videos
and through the process of working with
those editors I found that I need to
communicate a lot more and give more
guidance and more assets and all of that
and and then I brought Caitlin in for
that I'm like this is what I got I need
help what do I do I'm so excited about
we made a little intro for them oh
they're so cute and I made little pixel
versions of us and mochi our cat the
supervisor and it like animates and it's
soo big huge I kind of want to put them
on a t-shirt or something although it's
a little pre-emptive because we haven't
even announced everything Caitlyn gaming
but yeah I think that we should put them
on a t-shirt I wrote it down I put in to
do oh that's genius we should do that
for the launch we should we need to
order them right now so they come in
time in time for the launch okay today
yeah priority priorities the clouds yeah
okay I did I did a banner too for our
channel art and it's got little pixel
clouds but it was interesting as I
worked with these editors I was coming
up with like oh this editor did this I
really like that let's put this into the
framework for how all of them should
should do it and oh let's get them all
using the same font so that it's
consistent let's get them all using the
same sound effects and music so that's
all consistent let's add humor in
similar ways so that like there's
repeated jokes as you go from one editor
to the next so that it feels like a
continuation of the same channel instead
of divergent yeah things hitting
someone's face well and interestingly we
kind of have been like growing a guide
like that for our main channel yeah over
the past two years like we started a
document called how to content back when
we first started the channel and every
time we would think of something or
change something we would add it there
so it's like you know things like gosh
I'm trying to
well it's hard because they're things
specific to us and and and some of them
are broadly applicable yeah some are so
like a recent one a recent one is ever
since we did the can epoxy cook an egg
video and we bought the science robes
that I put on the content creation sheet
like like remember any time you're
testing something you know and you can
make it kind of like you are doing an
experiment bust out the science show
because you forget in the moment yeah
you can build it this repertoire of
repeated reason I added it on there it's
cause like after that video we did some
testing and experiments in future videos
and people were like where are the robes
or the science ropes and I was like Dean
you got to remember to do that so I
think it's that's actually a healthy
thing to to do for your own channel even
if you're not outsourcing you know to
make a little guide for yourself and
we're like the king and queen of making
guides for ourselves we have so many
cheat sheets we have like our
live-streaming cheat sheet our podcast
cheat sheet our video cheat sheet our
like emailing sponsors cheat sheet you
know because we wear so many hats we
need that though cuz we need to get in
those different modes if we were video
editing all the time or filming all the
time or reaching out to sponsors all the
time we wouldn't need those guides
that's in our heads but we need to like
put on our like different hats and we
need like reabsorb the knowledge that we
like I purged from our brain when we
moved one roll to the other one big
example of that is one that I just
completed wearing boxes before we're
just bored the tacks hat for a full 24
hours straight and did our taxes cuz
that's another thing that's something
that like okay I'm finally on board to
outsource but I've been I've just been
hesitant about outsourcing in general
like throughout life because I'm like
with taxes it's something that I've been
I've been doing my own taxes and they've
been complicated taxes since like 2013
but since I started a business actually
no since earlier I started business in
like 2009 yeah when I started my
business and so I've been learning taxes
and like teaching myself how to do it
for ten years and so it's like handing
it off seems like I've wasted a lot time
for learning but that that's when we're
like we have a guide for ourselves but
also I mean like that the hard thing is
tax has changed every year everything
changes all the time and it's not we
focus on it enough to keep up with it
yeah I think that kind of brings us
around to how this whole outsourcing has
changed our perspective on time work
money and all of that for everything
like I always kind of knew like one easy
example is kind of like mowing the lawn
you know or dealing with your yard and
we know that not everyone is you know
there's a lot of people in a position
where like that's not an option that's
not an option yeah but I think for us
it's when you're working for yourself
and if you can work more and make more
money like it's like what what is more
worth your time working more on your own
business or taking care of your own lawn
and stuff like that yeah work eight
hours and they can't work more than that
yeah which is why like when we were at
our normal jobs it was a lot like it
took a lot of convincing for me to
outsource a lot work you know justify
like even eating out is like a form of
outsourcing yeah cuz I mean other people
are procuring the food for you prepping
it coming up with the recipes coming up
with like what to make making it serving
it cleaning it up all of that jazz I
mean that's all people's time and effort
and the reason why it's more expensive
to eat out than just buying the raw
ingredients is because you have to pay
all those people for their time plus the
land plus everything you know yeah I
guess what I'm saying is like you know
it's it's almost something and I do want
to cook more because it's like cooking
and we're good cooks sometimes we don't
always have time but I'm trying to be
like more gentle on myself
for how often we eat out these days
because it's like it's a kind of another
form of outsourcing I mean you know we
probably eat it out like oh yeah it is
probably half the time but yeah half the
time isn't bad I guess it's not bad it
feels like a lot
we used to eat out like a couple times a
week yeah and now it's like half of our
meal that's within our power to change
as we continue to grow and outsource
more and yeah you know flex around our
time it's interesting to think of things
as outsourcing that I didn't really
think of this outsourcing before we were
working full time yeah it's true because
anything that can save you time even if
it's just simple things can can you know
cuz I don't know yeah it's well let me
see if I can wear this right for us all
time is equal in a way because I think
for other people who have jobs there's
like you know traditional jobs it's like
you have your time at work and then you
have the time when you're at home and
that home time is there like I can put
this into any pot that I want I can put
it in the personal time family time
productive time or whatever mm-hmm but
for us a hundred percent of our time is
that flat fully flexible time so we can
work unlimited amounts we can do an
unlimited amount into anything we want
and it's just like what do you get back
you know what I mean
so thinking about anything that we do in
our in our lives
any amount like anything that like if
you look at a pie chart of what takes up
our lifetime anything in that can be
potentially shifted around from one that
from yeah words guys yeah yeah I guess
that's what I went on to say but I think
that one of the reasons why gaming is so
exciting to us is because we get the
amount of time we have to put into
making a piece of content with gaming
and even with podcasts the amount of
time we put in verse the amount of
content we put out is very high as
opposed to our evident kale and main
channel well hi as in we get a lot of
content for the amount of time yeah so
it's like we can we can spend an hour
like playing a game we send that over
and that outsourcing I
that we can get that down to like 15 to
30 minutes of time spent managing that
project and then we get back ten minutes
potentially of entertaining high quality
footage so that's like like an hour and
a half maybe two ten minutes the podcast
is like you know two to three hours
between recording and editing to a whole
hour yeah which is really good for art
I've been some kaelin videos it's like
80 hours for 10 to 20 minutes yeah the
ratio is way way way difficult and we
know that the eminent Caitlyn main
videos that's like the main those will
always be a priority but one priority
really encouraging and and I think that
it maybe was it only happened because
your mom was here and she saw us like
managing that thing as we started up she
started though the evident Caitlyn
gaming videos so she was here and she
saw us starting to outsource that we
showed her some of the previews that
came in and she was curious to see how
they turned out
and you were talking with her the other
day yeah and she she was like so you
know it's kind of late and nothing was
on TV and even though like you know I
haven't tuned done in do streams because
I'm like Lana really like want to watch
video games but I was like I'll check
out the highlights cuz that you know I
wanted to see like how they turned out
and she was like they were really funny
like I would watch those again like if I
need a pick-me-up I'm gonna go back and
watch those hats and my mom like isn't
into gaming or anything like that so
just maybe happy that like someone who's
and of course she's my mom she's a
little bit buyers bias but but she
didn't watch the streams your mom was
very honest she tells things as they are
but yeah so it's a it was that was
encouraging that like someone who's not
cuz I don't think you need to like know
the game cuz more about like hanging out
with us like watching us make
goofy and it's not really about the game
cuz like I don't think that there's
almost any time in our highlights by
design that were just they were just
playing the game no it's all us interact
with each other interacting with the
game or just goofing around like on
something completely unrelated or just
engaging with the chat yes I think that
in some of our recent highlights one of
our editors has actually got us like
kind of interacting with the chat and in
a humorous way and everything so this
feels like we're all hanging out so
that's kind of what we're going for with
that but it is pretty encouraging to
hear that and get that reaction and
stuff yeah it was just exciting to
diversify you know because like for the
Evan and Caitlyn main channel we always
knew that in terms of what projects we
tackled we wanted it to be very diverse
but you know it's still project based
yeah um and so it's fun to do these
other side things that are not
necessarily project-based like this
podcast yeah and the gaming you know and
it's I don't know it feels like you know
we were diversifying ourselves within
the bubble of like projects you know for
our main videos but now I feel like
we're like diversifying ourselves next
level 2 which is fun so I think that
going forward in the future I think that
we're gonna settle down for now with
three main channels podcast everything
Caitlyn gaming yeah but like I don't
know could you see in the future even
more channels maybe the thing I struggle
with is like so so with the podcast 100%
makes sense to have it be on its own
channel yes with gaming 100% makes sense
to have it on its own channel 1% but
some things like I wonder I struggle a
little bit like doesn't make sense to
have it on the main channel or have it
okay I forgot Evan in Caitlyn to but oh
my gosh you know full video that okay
there's I have something amazing vision
so we meet we mean it
April Fool's video where we did a DIY
cat bed and it's just like a quick like
20 second video we posted on social and
on our second Channel but it's just like
we order supplies from Amazon we dump
them out and then we put the Box on the
ground and mokey Hobson you spoiled it I
mean if you haven't seen if I won't see
it below yeah but um anyways we post on
the second channel yeah just to have a
place to host it like 15k view that's
not even the exciting part the exciting
part to me is we posted it and boosted
it from our other channels and for the
first five days it kind of got average
views for evident in Caitlyn too which
means not much at all yeah it's very
little very little and you know three or
four days in after we posted a free push
it on Evan Caitlyn community to have all
of our socials all of that it started
taking off all by itself yeah
which that to me is the most encouraging
and exciting thing ever because that
shows that on a channel that is very
small I think we only had like maybe
just around a thousand subs over there
yeah and not that much like active posts
or anything we gave it a little bit of a
boost from our other socials and then it
took off independently people have been
finding it via like browse or search or
something like that which to me this is
just like it's very encouraging for me
to us protect to potentially start more
side channels yeah like I hope that
happens with gaming yeah but it is
interesting thinking about like future
channels in the future yeah yeah like so
one one easy example that we've kind of
talked about before is evident Caitlyn
Tuesdays are more vlog like casual
videos I have done one of those in a
while
partially just because it still takes
time and we've been busy with all these
other things it's like what what bucket
do you put it into like we mentioned
before but you know videos like that are
they still best on our main channel or
should we start a second probably for
that would keep them on Evan Caitlin
well cuz we asked everyone on Instagram
and Twitter and people said keep it on
the main yeah but you know it's the the
people who like don't want to see it
aren't gonna respond if you're like
don't do that crap but we did we even
had a vote which is anonymous and anyone
could say no and even in the vote we
kind of got that but anyways like what
if in the future we want to expand even
more what if we want to do like a travel
vlog or Caitlyn does my makeup or I do
Caitlyn's makeup or we do like just like
a ridiculous or like a tech tech stuff a
tech stuff yeah what's up I think tech
stuff would definitely start a new
channel for that if we took it on
because it just wouldn't fit at all and
any of the others neither would like a
travel vlog yeah I know
I'm like man what do we have so many
channels I'm like that's because
consistency and repetition is what makes
things work on YouTube yeah and if you
spread yourself too thin but and just do
like 4 videos a year exactly yeah
exactly so that's kind of like the
struggle I don't want to start another
channel unless there's something we're
gonna maintain yeah gently yeah so
that's weekly a lot of our thoughts on
all of that
I think that's gonna add to I want to
play a game you wanna play
[Music]
all right - Walt Caitlin pulls up her
notes cuz I'm already organized I
already have mine up check that out I'm
done oh oh no no no so in this game
we're gonna be reading quotes from
movies and they have to be kind of like
big enough quotes that people who've
watched the movie should get it but I
think we're gonna try to like deceive
each other by not reading them in the
right voice and kind of giving them
without contact well and this is a
suggestion on the podcast um by Charlie
extra Thank You charlie yeah yeah
similar similar to our lyric reading
game but with movie quotes so if you
guys have any good games we should play
leave them in the comments too because
we're always on the lookout for more
games because these are really fun yeah
okay so yeah movie quotes you wanna go
first yeah so so we're gonna read it not
necessarily in the voice of the
character first and then if the person
needs a little hint you can like do your
impersonation so so this one might be
really easy might be really hard cuz I
heard it a lot but I had forgotten it's
from this movie movie so you're killing
me smalls okay so what if I hadn't given
you this though heroes get remembered
but legends never die
follow your heart kid and you'll never
go wrong what do you have gone it with
that I might not have gotten it with I
might like know the quote but I'd I
don't know if I would have known that
that was Sandlot yeah right I mean kid
kid being in the line - giving me a clue
yeah okay next time oh yeah
I'll give you something with the hard
ones I wanted to give an example of like
oh why not to do in this game here let
me go let me go okay okay
[Laughter]
you're a baboon and I'm not winking Oh
easy ones yeah
okay you've got red on you what that
could be anything you've got red on you
Kill Bill look do you want me do it in
the voice yeah
I've got red on you water you know it's
British oh you're on the right track
thinking Kill Bill cuz like what would
that red be blood mm-hmm got red on you
like Outback person okay British I
already said British okay is it James
Bond no so context rent the red this is
a line that's repeated in the movie
again and again at least twice but it's
like it's like a recurring joke the
second time the red is blood the first
time it is Expendables no it's um I'm an
action movie kind of a comedy action
comedy dark comedy we were talking about
this kind of comedy recently specific
genre of like comedy + action + horror
I've got red on you can give me another
line there's not all you got that's all
you got isn't it I'm giving you a lot of
clues we were just talking about this
movie like two nights ago on our walk
what's so funny is like I predicted how
bad I'd be it involves zombies Oh Shaun
of the net so the mean the main
character it has like ink on a shirt
first
it is like you've got red on you and
then later on it's blood yeah no I don't
remember that part I only got to do
context clues I don't know okay this is
something that like and all of mine are
like potentially easy if you know them I
guess I didn't try the hardest for like
I do things like medium hardness okay
okay I got one I got one
I'm so glad I was unconscious for all of
this there you go Oh have fun with that
one I'm so glad I was unconscious for
all of this okay so it's a movie where
someone is unconscious or something that
happens
okay I'll even
no we're just really bad at impressions
both okay
what's wrong with this chimp and the bug
can we get back to me
chimp and the bug what's wrong with this
chimp and the bug can we get back to me
okay well me that while we do give you
the most unconscious and chimp like what
movie has like a chimp you're on the
right track though it's not jungle buck
but there is a jungle is it George of
the jungle and it's animated okay let me
give you one more it's a good thing
you're not a big fat guy or this would
be really difficult Emperor's New Groove
yeah yep you know what's funny what's
that one of my close quotes that I would
know okay okay wait okay so the
unconscious one I remember that one now
okay okay but what other one from chimp
in the bug I think I was like during a
cutscene
oh wait oh it's got to be when they're
all animals oh yeah yeah what do you
mean cutscene it's when they're all like
animals cuz I was taking the formula so
it's got to be yet oh yeah that line
yeah
but unconscious that's cuz he was
unconscious and he was kidnapped yeah
all right can I do another one yeah yeah
cuz I'm really excited about this again
I'm gonna go for in the same way from
hardest to least hard yeah that's a good
order an Emperor's New Groove good move
good movie I wanna watch it again
yeah we do you know that that's the one
with the hair yeah those are like the
things we quote like all the time like
on the weekly almost okay
do the chickens have large talons Oh
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh does it ring a chord
with you no no that's not that's doesn't
like there's like like strike a chord
within your memories a little bit okay
okay this this is this is uh this is a
little easier I see that you are
drinking 1% cuz you're not you gonna be
drinking whole if you wanted to I was
trying to like read it in a void away oh
my gosh I was it was on the tip of my
tongue but then 1% oh you you might have
gone in with talons
maybe my I may not have gotten it I if
you've done it in the voice obviously if
your talks oh yeah
but if you like but if you like to the
chickens of large towns yeah but you
can't I can't yeah I can't make it easy
for you I'm so like I think I'm like as
I play this game with you I think I'm
learning what I can do better next round
figure out the difficulty figure out the
difficulty and stuff yeah okay man that
free gasoline fight accident this is a
school for ants there's so many one that
I couldn't do cuz they're like - yeah
okay let me do another yeah but beneath
the clothes we find
man and beneath the man we find his
nucleus what have I seen this movie yeah
it's another movie we quote some lines
from beneath the man beneath beneath the
clothes we find a man and beneath the
man we find his dot dot dot nucleus mmm
is that a movie we've watched recently
no not recently
is it animated no it's live action it's
live action well Jonah comedy Ace
Ventura no it's not that old we we quote
there's one line from this we quote a
lot we put too much kung pao I can any
one word line you know you did one for
each of these didn't some I did okay
all the other ones like you either have
just a small of a chance of getting it
or it's way too odd okay this is
Smallville check okay yeah um I'm just
gonna because I didn't write it down so
I'm just gonna go off my memory so I'm
just gonna do a portion of a line the
Lord's chips what the Lord's chips
this is Monty Python but beneath the
clothes we find a man I've only seen
that movie once
really and there's a long time ago we
should watch tickets there's it's so
it's definitely a quotable okay my thing
that was a good one though cuz like you
got it with with work in there there's a
good level okay this I just have no clue
if you're gonna get it with my hint or
not okay I love you I know
wait was that the line yeah I like I
said you use it half of it I said half
of it
wow that was that was well-planned I
love you I love you too you know it was
just love you I was just I love you I
know people Oh one person says I love
you no one says I know yeah I feel like
that's something that has happened in
many movies where one person says really
responds I know hmm
can you give me another clue that won't
give it away no really nothing you can't
tell me like the genre is it live-action
or cartoon so the well it's the woman
that says I love you and the man that
says I know are you sure this isn't in
multiple movies no this is a very famous
scene from a very famous movie yeah but
that may not be the only movie where
someone says I love you and the person
responds I know okay is the man like
some kind of like superhero or like
famous person in the movie not really
he's more of a scoundrel a scoundrel
yeah
when I hear scoundrel I think Jack
Sparrow but it's not him okay scoundrel
yeah okay it's in the future in the
future so dad I feel like that line
isn't a lot of big movies I love you I
know yeah really yeah okay Google search
I love you I know and see what comes up
okay as the number one result
no quote yeah yeah yeah yeah well yeah
it comes up in the first but it wasn't
Star Wars
I went vote below in the comments if you
if you got this right away and if that's
the only correct answer for this for
that quote really try to like right
fight her way okay okay okay okay fine
fine
I am correct okay so this is two people
all right you kind of need to so the
first one how are things going mr.
Torrence the second person things could
be better Lloyd things could be a whole
lot better
office space no this should be easy
because you have both of their names
Lloyd and Floyd's yes I've made you
watching ha ha ha
how are things going mr. Torrance things
could be better Lloyd things could be a
whole lot better it's a genre we have
not covered in this game yet ok it's not
comedy or Disney or yes
Oh think about the name flora for you
Lauren Turin Gino mr. Torrance mr.
Torrance what do you think about the
name
dizzy torrent a lot of stuff even mr.
torrent that we hear about on the news
mr. Toren giving away all the videos
sharing sharing videos Oh mr. Torrance
tea no no okay
there's another quote that is famous
from this movie they didn't do because
it would give it away but it involves
mrs. torrents mrs. also in mrs. torrents
a horror movie was it a good horror
movie yeah the best the ring
no it's older because the ring is one of
the best the ring is really good I
remember watching one really bad horror
movie where I was like like where
there's like like a sight on it the
satanic cult or something like that and
they're trying to steal the wife's baby
or something
I thought neither of us like that though
oh that was um Rosemary's Baby yeah I
think that okay I wasn't crazy about
that okay this is newer than that
yeah sounds pretty old right it was
newer than that hmm the most there is a
super famous quote from this that I
can't say wasn't that that film that was
filmed all in one take was it no I'm
gonna try to do impressions but it might
be bad
how are things going mr. Torrance things
could be better Lloyd things could be a
whole lot better okay looking at me like
that should completely get away like
okay what come on okay so for the other
one that involves mrs. Torrance I'm not
gonna say the whole thing yeah cuz it'll
definitely give it away but what if I
just say mrs. Torrance for those of you
listening I'm just like shrugging and
holding up my hands and wobbling them
like what am I supposed to do with that
here's Johnny oh oh yeah yeah yeah
I know it um there at the hotel yeah he
freezes in the maze all work and no play
all work and no play makes Johnny a boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
painful painful journey okay this is an
easy hard one it's really easy if you
know that the line yeah
life moves pretty fast is that the
entire line if you don't stop and look
around once in a while oh you could miss
it oh I know this coral I know this
quote you know this quote it's a great
movie it's a great older movie it's kind
of older yeah yeah it's older like came
out like like a fairly older okay movie
you watched it when we were kids
mm-hmm they're not that old I probably
didn't watch it until I was like 18 or
early 20s but I think it is older I
think okay I don't know I don't give you
too many hints okay mm-hmm yeah if you
don't okay
hello let me be a little bit faster so I
was trying to throw you off I like but I
know the quad right so life moves pretty
fast if you don't stop and look around
once in a while you could miss it
are you doing an impression no oh my god
oh my god what genre comedy comedy
comedy for sure okay any more clues this
is frustrating why don't you take a day
off and think about it no day off and
think think about it no no no no that's
that's not a quote sorry oh I thought
you really continued want me to take a
day off and we'll come back to the
podcast a day later no no it's a very
strong hint it's a hint but it's a hint
but it's not a collet oh my god okay for
those of you like know it I'm sorry I'm
sorry this is so painful okay so someone
takes a day off to think about this it's
a comedy movie yeah I thought I could be
way better at this game so much better
the lyrics came but I know this quote
Yeah right it's a very big quote okay I
thought that this was gonna be so easy I
didn't write down a second quote do you
don't have to you can give me other
hints like about the movie okay um you
know there's it's a man that says the
quote right it is a male that's a quote
let's see guys what hey can we give her
that won't spoil the whole game it's
live action it's live action yes okay
yes the the main character is in high
school I think even though he looks
older is it Ferris Bueller's Day
yeah yeah I should have known that one
although like I've watched that movie
like once but I don't know if I would
have liked I know the quote yeah because
it's a famous quote so what well quote
what do you have gone for for Ferris
Bueller's Day I have no idea because I
only watch the movie once again I mean
like it was a good movie I enjoyed it
but it's not one that I like quote oh
yeah yeah like I don't quote it or think
about it but what's interesting is like
with this game if you if we choose a
movie that we quote we can't use those
quotes exactly that's right yeah yeah
well I did try to choose some movies
that I quote but quotes from them it's
like the nacho libre Libre cuz we always
say like eats for fun but like one thing
I tried to I wanted to do Forrest Gump
but if I said my mama always said life
was like a box of chocolates you get it
right away
run Forrest run you get right away so
what I was gonna say now like the last
quote I have isn't at all good so I'm
not even gonna say it I'm gonna delete
it before you make fun of me okay okay I
have one that I'm so excited I know
exactly what I'm doing that my time okay
we can stay up late swapping manly
stories and in the morning I'm making
waffles who I I'm not even sure I've
seen it you've seen this movie I've seen
it yes uh brothers know what brothers
know I can understand why okay wait wait
so say it again we can stay up late
swapping manly stories and in the
morning
I'm making waffles is it a male or
female saying that it's a male it's a
male saying that to another male yes
it's animated animated oh man that
completely threw me I was going down a
completely different path animator we
can stay up late swapping manly stories
and then I'm making waffles and in the
morning I make it laughs oh I have no
clue it's a nonhuman saying it tween
non-human what but they are not the same
kind of they are not the same species
is it really is that are the animals one
is one is an animal and one is a spirit
no it's just not a human I can't tell
you what it is
okay an animal and the nonhuman but not
an animal it's not Aladdin
no it's 3d animated go 3d animated is it
like the the one like the treasure
treasure island that was house 2d
animated house through the enemy no no
2d animated 3d maybe or do you say like
in the voice yeah we'd stay up late swap
in manly stories and in the morning I'm
making busts rattles what's 3d animated
I used to quote this all the time with
my brother I'm like it was kind of me
tell you when the movie came out ah we
were maybe in high school
I feel bad I make it once I just don't
remember too many 3d animated movies
comedies me yeah it was very big very
enjoyable that's not this is the first
of a series not Toy Story but similar to
Toy Story and and Incredibles it was the
first one in a series what Eddie Murphy
was the voice actor that said this line
have I see this movie yes
you move one ordered resent see in this
movie Mike Myers is the care force of
the character that this person is
talking to you this is Spaceballs
no sign of Space Jam the Space Jam no
yeah
see Sam was live action plus to do yeah
sure how you seen me see this movie so I
have to have seen it I mean I'm the main
character is green flubber now in 3d
animator
main characters green there's not a
human but not an animal main character
is green he's green he's like he's like
onions Shrek any of those quotes when he
first meets donkey and donkeys like
super excited he's gonna be his best
friend and he's like trying to be all
buddy-buddy and he like invites himself
into his house huh he's like we're gonna
stay up all night SWAT manly stories and
in the morning I make it waffles man I
have very few memories back do you
remember like thank you compensating
much I think he's compensating for
something cuz like super big I I'm
thinking like maybe I have only seen
track in little bits that's cuz like
Shrek is a really good movie okay cuz
like I'm not I'm not fully sure I've
seen all of track which is maybe a
little crazy I think I might have seen a
little bit of Shrek 2
and maybe some of Shack through hey I
don't know I feel like I know girls are
like onions I know I remember oh guys
are like onions I remember that but
maybe this because I've heard people say
it I think you know there might have
been I think I might have watched Shrek
I'm like an airplane or something like
that where I was like I only watched
like you know some of it or like check
is good movie
lots of innuendos ok well maybe we'll
have to do that watch that again
sometime yeah I want to do the one I'm
most excited about
mmm is this your last one like should I
prepare my last one because I have
several left uh yeah Wow Wow the time
has really gotten away with us and if
you get it right away I get a repeat
okay
everything in this room is eatable oh
that's um uh Charlie and Chuck oh dang
okay I got to redo this but I get to
finish this quote ooh
even I am eatable but that's called
cannibalism my dear children and is in
fact frowned upon in most societies
okay when they open Disneyland in 1956
nothing worked
yeah but John in the pipe if the Pirates
of the Caribbean breaks down the Pirates
don't eat the tourists that know yeah
two different people okay
I just guessed that because I was
thinking carnival and zombies yeah when
they opened Disneyland in 1956 nothing
worked another person yeah but John
Jessup Ark yes you use context clues and
like figure it out man I just want to
keep on playing this game we'll just
have to do one more and then we'll wrap
it up and then we'll we'll play this
again in the future
yeah there were horses and Amanda on
fire and I killed a guy with a trident
hmm I get so excited and I want you to
like stop and not anymore so I can win
like okay nobody makes me bleed my own
blood oh don't say anything more don't
you want any more I know you know this
one but I I it's a hard one cuz it'll be
it might be hard to place what movie
it's in but you I bet you could like say
it like it said like I just read it but
I bet if you tried you could say it in
the way it said in the movie no one
makes me bleed my own blood
no no you basically said it yeah I mean
you're really better if you can if
you're not watching right now evan is
like like his face is right next to the
mic and you're rubbing your eyeball I'm
massaging my brain through my eyeballs I
know this no one makes me believe I own
blood nobody yeah yeah dang it this is
probably well like you're you're feeling
with like the Ferris Bueller it's like
you know the quote you know the movie
you
you know you've seen it and yet you just
like can't say the words because like
the memory is in long-term storage or
something and it's just like it's like
you're looking through your filing a
system and you know that you put that
piece of paper there but you just can't
find that piece of paper again I think
so one thing that um this came out
during a time where a lot of other very
quotable movies came out that all kind
of had the same set of actors they're
all the same genre similar sense of
humor and that I think that's one of the
things that makes it kind of tricky is
it animated or live-action live-action
there are a bunch of live-action comedy
movies all but the same group of actors
we've quoted some of those movies
already today they all came up with the
same within the same like X amount of
years span it's all the same kind of
humor it's like the same group of actors
it's so funny because like there are
clusters like that there are clusters
and and then some like the weirdest
thing that like just blows my mind every
now and then like Armageddon and deep
impact bug's life and magic ones the
prestige and there's one other magical
one that came out the same time well I
think there's a name for that really
phenomenon yeah they both start so long
in the past and they both somehow come
out in the same like month there's a
name for that phenomena I watched I
think about it there's a thing for that
thing I watched that thing I watched
like a video about that phenomenon no
one makes me believe my own but nobody
um can you go one other line from that
hmm I didn't write down any others with
the two quotes I can think of use a word
in the title ah shucks yeah
it involves a sport of sorts um it was
the
the stuck-up person on the other side of
the team yes like the main guy both win
we both always win about to wrap up and
I got excited all right so my thing of
the week is probably like the thing that
brings me the most joy is our latest
evident Caitlyn gaming video it's
unraveled - it's a game that we've
really been enjoying it so cute it was
the game itself was my thing of the week
yeah and I think the highlight from it
just like really it just gives me
excited for the future
yeah and this gets me super pumped in
general if you're curious about the
gaming videos I would say watch that one
yes yeah because that's like that's kind
of what we would like them to all be
like yeah that's also it's like three
like you know it was like after three
chances of like getting to give guidance
and feedback and everything I'm excited
where all of them are going but I think
that the shows like the potential and
also I think that it's interesting like
we like all sorts of games we just want
to play all the games but I think that
some games make for better highlights in
general yeah I think we're also kind of
like the same way on evident Caitlyn how
we like keep on revising what type of
project we do so that it makes for a
good video I think we're gonna keep on
doing the same thing with video games
we're gonna play games that will lead to
good highlights yeah and and I think
that I'm just so pumped guys I just get
like it's really exciting so check that
out
so oh and we'll have a link in the
description yeah so my thing the week is
actually and a lot of y'all probably
already seen this it's um the latest
mark Rober video where he he and
smartereveryday
make a rocket-powered golf club yeah
that one up on trending that was like
always on trend yeah but like one thing
and I always like marks videos but one
thing about this one that I thought was
interesting is he went a little bit more
into the iterations anything he showed a
love of the build a little bit more of
the
and a little bit more of the fails and
stuff where I feel like a lot of times
the videos are like 90% demonstrating
the finished thing and maybe 10% um kind
of showing the progress but this one was
like maybe 50/50 I thought it was really
interesting and I liked it felt like a
lot more behind the scenes and it was
entertaining just cuz there were a lot
of parts that were slightly less
polished yeah I did have a different
vibe to it the whole thing very good
yeah yeah so I would I would recommend
that if you like watching entertaining
videos and also like to see the fails
involved and I think it's really cool to
like just see smart people doing cool
stuff yeah it's fun to see those two
interact so alright guys thanks so much
for joining us on today's podcast it's
been really fun kind of talking about
this and sharing all of our thoughts and
feeling this about the past week and the
future and just getting really excited
about where this whole career path of
art is that we're making up as we go is
going yeah and if you like today's
episode make sure to share it with a
friend we really appreciate all the
reviews that have been getting in we
read every single one and it just makes
our day every time we read one of those
and we'll look forward to seeing in the
next time
[Music]